we always strive for authenticity with
the character as much as possible to
bring them off the page of the comic
book and put them on screen in a way
that would make that you know 3% of the
hardest [ __ ] fanboys pumped up about it
and miraculously by pleasing them I
think we pleased a much wider audience
as well please don't make the supersuit
green or animated are there a lot of
prototypes when I put on the first
Deadpool suit it was a tough thing to
get right you know a brilliant designer
buy them a rush anklet film illusions
made it and he must have never slept
because we have such an accelerated
schedule but when I put that suit on the
first time I actually wept when we got
it right as it was it was as though we
just pulled it right out of our minds
and onto the screen so it was a pretty
spectacular feeling to get that right
it's not that's a big part of it I mean
that's that first impression that
everybody gets when they see photos of
us treating the streets I would have to
say that that was a big one for us eh
you may be wondering why the red suit
well that's so bad guys can't see me
bleed this guy's got the right idea he
wore the brown pants they'd be great
kind of hoax to Deadpool's that it
actually starts off in a pretty
emotionally depraved and devastating
place and his character his cancer so
that sort of lays the groundwork for all
these big comedic payoffs later on in
the film what if I told you we can cure
you and give you abilities most men only
dream of I'd say that you sound like an
infomercial but not a good one like Slap
Chop more shake weighty Deadpool's voice
I I've always kind of had a an affinity
we've always had that sort of pleasing
symmetry in our and the way we speak so
it wasn't hard that was that was the
easiest part the hardest part I think
was just the lead-up for me it was 11
years for the rest the team Rhett Reese
Paul Wernick and Tim Miller was five
years and you know right up until
yesterday I'm we're still working on the
next one
you're probably thinking this was a
superhero movie but that guy in the suit
just turned that other guy into a kebab
surprise this is a different kind of
superhero story for me personally to get
nominated for Golden Globe is a huge
personal achievement but in a way it's
overshadowed by the fact that Deadpool
itself got nominated and I think in some
strange way I'm more proud of that just
because it breaks a strange kind of
glass ceiling for the genre it's a big
moment for all of us you know and it's a
huge honor and it also really speaks to
the level of commitment that this whole
team had you know every single one of us
gave the last drop of blood for this Tim
Miller Rhett Reese Paul Wernick myself
invert man it's a pinch me moment I
never let the movie get made let alone
what I'd be sitting here staring down a
barrel that thing shooting for variety
I am very turned on right now
notification squad that's about the most
serious Deadpool trailer you're going to
see is basically like a for your
consideration because the Oscar
nominations are coming up so Deadpool
might win a couple really big awards and
two second big thing is that he's
pushing for a Wolverine crossover movie
so we got to freak out about this there
is a new round of the spider-man
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video be sure to click that Bell
to enable alerts so you don't miss
anything so we'll talk about the awards
stuff first because that's happening
tomorrow night and then we'll talk about
the Wolverine team-up movie that Ryan
Reynolds is trying to get Hugh Jackman
to come back for which is a huge deal
all by itself - so like Ryan Reynolds
says they're basically breaking the
glass ceiling for comic book movies with
this kind of nomination well you know a
movie in the tone of Deadpool there's
been a lot of serious comic-book movies
everyone always wondered if Christopher
Nolan might win an Oscar for his Dark
Knight trilogy because you know even
though all the films aren't as good as
the other films like dark night for
instance still stands is one of the best
comic book movies of all time so
typically the people that vote on the
different awards for like Golden Globes
Oscars like the really big movie Awards
do not like Comic Book Fair they tend to
favor serious movies about serious
issues Hollywood itself if you've ever
watched one of these award shows it's
kind of boring because Hollywood takes
itself so seriously in one of the
reasons why Deadpool deserves to win an
award is because it completely disrupted
Hollywood last year not just comic book
movies but just movies in general it is
now the biggest rated-r film of all time
in one of the biggest x-men films if not
almost the biggest x-men film that Fox
has ever made so like Ryan Reynolds says
a lot of that is because of the script
the script was really strong it just
reinforces the idea that no matter what
your spectacles are you have to have an
awesome script just a hammer that home
the script itself was nominated for a
wg8 Writers Guild of America Award so
great script great creative team behind
the scenes he was also nominated for an
award in editing so just like the way
the film was made the people that made
it were all nominated for awards so
aren't you so happy now
most of that team is coming back for the
second movie I know there was a lot of
drama with the director we can talk
about that more in Deadpool two videos
this is mostly awards hype Deadpool
probably won't win just because like I
said Hollywood the people that vote on
these awards do not like comic book
films but because it disrupted Hollywood
so much it deserves to win so let me
know in the comments why do you think
the Deadpool deserves to win an Oscar or
a Golden Globe Award now it hasn't
earned any Oscars nominations yet those
are due till next week so as I'm posting
this video they haven't announced who's
nominated for Oscars but it's already
been nominated for a couple Golden
Globes which is happening tomorrow night
Best Motion Picture in Best Actor for
Ryan Reynolds in a Musical or Comedy so
I do think because it's in the Comedy
category it has a much better chance of
winning Ryan Reynolds has a much better
chance of winning than if it were in the
drama category that's the really hard
one to win that's the one that they take
super seriously like if your film isn't
about some topical world event then
you're probably not gonna win an award
looping it back around to Deadpool - he
said that basically like up until the
time that they were filming this promo
they were working on Deadpool - he
didn't mean that they stopped working on
Deadpool - it's gonna take them a little
while longer before they start shooting
they have to announce who cable is
playing so I'll be doing a whole bunch
of Deadpool videos once they start
announcing stuff so next big thing we
need to talk about Wolverine Deadpool
team-up movie what the hell's going on
people were like oh my god is Logan
gonna be like a Deadpool team-up movie
Ryan Reynolds Hugh Jackman then the
Logan director came out and said no you
know there's no Deadpool in this movie
because people were asking them is there
gonna be a crossover is there gonna be a
team-up they were basically saying that
you know no Logan exists by itself it's
like a self-contained movie they didn't
say anything about post-credit scene so
when everybody's expecting is that
there'll be some sort of Deadpool in tag
that has nothing to do with the Logan
movie they just kind of like tack it on
at the end of the film so no Deadpool
inside Logan because the tone is just so
different from Deadpool that was Ryan
Reynolds big thing he's like I would
love to do a Wolverine team-up movie but
it would have to be its own separate
thing so he
jackman came back and was like you know
that sounds really interesting but it'd
be kind of tricky because Logan is
supposed to be his last movie as
Wolverine but never say never because he
is still super fit he could always come
back and do more it's just that for the
last year he was saying this is his last
time to put the claws on and I think a
lot of that had to do with the creative
direction of the character in the x-men
universe at Fox but now there's all this
talk about rebooting everything from a
creative perspective Bryan Singer has
left the franchise and they're sort of
retooling the core x-men movies before
they push forward into like a Dark
Phoenix arc so in the way that Marvel
sort of like separated from the
corporate parent and Marvel Studios went
off by itself Kevin Feige got a lot more
control the actors got a lot more
excited about coming back to do more
films I think the same thing will happen
with you Jackman so it doesn't guarantee
that they're gonna do crossover movie
it's just that Bryan Reynolds is pushing
for one really hard after Deadpool 2 so
what I'll do next week is I'll post
another video for like the top stories
that I think they should do for
something like that believe all your
Deadpool video requests in the comments
below make a geek 6807 you're this
week's Spider Man giveaway winner be
sure to private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there's gonna be some
more comic book stuff happening this
weekend but I will be posting some more
x-men Legion next week so get ready for
the Legion TV show that's coming in
February well you guys wait for that to
post you can click here to learn all
about Thor Ragnarok aka Planet Hulk and
you can click here to rewatch the Logan
trailer thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys in the next video